servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video mit einer sache die
eigentlich schon in youtube museum steht
und zwar machen wir heute ein wer bin
ich mit den wenigen bevorzugte wieder
losgeht und kurze info ich wollte in
dieser folge nicht spoilern deswegen
habe ich die namen der youtuber einfach
in die beschreibung beschrieben ganz und
in der beschreibung stehen so dass die
leute die nicht gespart werden wollen
selbst mit raten wollen das video
anschauen können alle die ich vorher
schon wissen wollen und wen es geht
schon die beschreibung und jetzt viel
spaß mit dem video
na da bin ich wer du bist ich habe mich
ganz weit weniger angekündigt aber bist
du vielleicht bist du dir sicher oder
habe ich für das einer maske auf ich hab
dich als wie angekündigt aber erstens
sehe ich dich gerade nicht könnte es
jeder sein du könntest war auch ein hund
sein der für sein pc sitzt oder
commander krieger wie dies commander
krieger confirmed wählen ich haben uns
jeweils ein lied über rausgesucht wir
haben die möglichkeit drei abo fragen zu
stellen
merck reiseverboten also weniger hat
quasi für mich eine person rausgesucht
und ich habe für ihre person rausgesucht
wir fragen dann jeweils wer wie selbst
sind ihr kennt es wahrscheinlich sowieso
dann legen wir los wenig ich fange an
ja okay für die männlich wir haben auch
gesagt es sind deutschsprachige user bzw
abgesagt ist ein deutschsprachiger
youtuber und natürlich meine frage mit
ja beantwortet wird darf man noch mal
fragen stellen bin ich älter als 18
mache ich gaming videos naja du machst
ja habe ich mir als hundert tausend
abonnenten die hab ich mehr als eine
million abonnenten handy haus ist hallo
ich gehe mal davon aus dass gesagt bin
ich ein säugetier bin ich ein tier der
gattung homo sapiens java junge jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt leistete säubern bin
ich ein säugetier wenig halt dich fest
okay halt dich fest bin ich ein
säugetier der gattung homo sapiens das
regelmäßig
nahrung zu sich nimmt und in einer
überdachten behausung wohnt da bin ich
mir nicht so sicher aber ich glaube ich
antwortet ja und ich weiß bin ich
männlich 1 habe ich was mit gaming zu
tun zu tun hat oder hatte ich was mit
games zu tun
ich würde sagen ja würde sagen ja ich
würde ja er habe ich in der letzten zeit
game video davon kann geplant
nein nein sagt er ist ja du bist dann
bin ich deutscher also in deutschland
geboren
ich würde sagen ja wohl nicht in
deutschland
ich würde sagen ja wohne ich in köln
ich verfolgte person persönlich das ist
mein kanal schon zwei jahre oder älter
ja mach ich komme die videos kommen wir
die ist ein dehnbarer begriff
also du meinst sketche oder wie nein
einfach so unterhaltungs mäßig ja könnte
man sagen könnte man sagen glaube ich
kann man sagen hat es mich schon mal
getroffen hast du mich schon mal
getroffen
ja aber das weißt du dich das weißt du
nicht also scheiße dass das kannst du
nicht wissen das wissen so wenige leute
mache ich peric placement ich guck mal
kurz auf den kanal
ja habe ich mir ist ein halbe million
abonnenten
ja ja ja ja und ich bin ein gaming kanal
joão warte mal dass die sache habe ich
die person schon mal getroffen
ob du dich selbst schon mal getroffen
hast ja keine ahnung dass das weiß ich
gar nicht also okay war war die person
auf der gamescom 2015 also weiter auf
der gamescom 2015
ich kann dir sagen die person war auf
dem video dessen bilden
bin ich weiß nein nein nein das hat
weniger mit oder 496.000 ja hab ich über
300.000 abonnenten nein hast du nicht
was ist china jetzt bin ich wieder dran
habe ich schon mal mit musik zu tun
gehabt also auf meinem kanal habe ich
schon mal musik gemacht doch am kanal
tricky frage ich glaube fast nicht mehr
ich glaube nicht so schwierig wäre hat
mehr macht den gaming entertainment ist
auf dem video ads
ich kenne die person ist gerade nicht
hatte ich bevor ich aufgehört auf den
videos hochzuladen regelmäßig minecraft
auf einem kanal hoch
nein du bist ein bisschen auf der
falschen irgendwie monopoly des player
mit 50.000 abonnenten
naja so direkt hatten wir so noch gar
nicht ob sie überhaupt kein gaming kanal
das haben wir schon mal gehabt ist kein
game hochgeladen aber hat mit ihm zu tun
ok als fergie you'd ja dann hatte ich
andere werte keinen auftritt auf den
video days in berlin hat eine bilden
auftritt bild die mainzer im rahmen von
der show oder so ja genau
also so wie wie die halt zum beispiel
dass er dann aufgetreten sind oder wer
war noch alberto ich gar nicht was unter
300.000 ist halt auch relativ ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass wir kämpfen was
eigentlich schon fast 100% meinst du
hatte ich schon mit der person hatte ich
mir selbst persönlich zu tun
also du meinst auftreffen irgendwie ja
schonmal oder oder kontakt mal etwas wie
skype oder auf ein teamspiel gesprochen
miteinander
das glaube ich nicht ich kann dazu
nichts sagen aber getroffen müsste
eigentlich schon
also ich getroffen würde ich ja sagen
aber ich kannte den tipp geben es sich
wahrscheinlich nicht anders sind wenn du
weißt dass ich die person betroffener
passt passt du dann auch dabei was du
dabei als ich mich selbst betroffener
okay dann kann es eigentlich in
habe ich mich selbst auf dem es muss
eigentlich dass sein hatte ich nicht
selbst auf dem society event getroffen
nein es waren die welt am richter zur
seite obwohl ich im youtube haus wer ist
der typ eingezogen aus europa nahm raus
also jetzt in wohnen
petri droht pilz paletten ja so die aber
die ist ja nicht männlich zumindest
nicht peterle und herr bergmann glaube
ich dann ja dann nein dann ein
das vielleicht ich geb dir auch mal den
tipp vielleicht bist doch momentan beim
falschen spiel
es hat sich sagen ja vielleicht bist du
gerade beim falschen spiel das da nur
gesagt
also ich hab die person schon mal
getroffen als ich besoffen war aber es
war nicht auf dieser website werden wo
er ist so oft war wahrscheinlich besorgt
man sich über getroffen hat oder doch
denkt hat in unserem channel sein der
mit was die tochter unterwegs auf den
berliner video ist längst zu kompliziert
ich denke ich zu kompliziert oder ex
viel zu komplizierte habe ich mich
selbst im rahmen eines events um die
video days gamescom betroffen
ja ok wo wollen wir noch zusammen
unterwegs
wie war noch zusammen unterwegs bei
leistungen standing zum beispiel ja habe
ich mich selbst bei last man standing
getroffen
ok alles klar ja ich sage ich erkannte
gestern falsche richtung weil du bist
nicht allein um die person an sich
selbst ich werde mich nicht an mir
selbst erinnern
ja mach ich selbst so comedy oder
reallife konnte ja ersteres comedy würde
ich sagen ja ich kenne keinen comedy
youtube unter 300.000 abonnenten locker
nicht doch natürlich fast 100 prozent
hunderte mein tipp mal gehen also mehr
in die in die richtige schiene comedy
was kann das noch sein
comedy komplex sein was noch sketches
parodien trage heute was du was du da
fragst was ist comedy auf youtube comedy
auf youtube ist entweder krank oder
parodien die fränkische alain prost
mache ich mich in meinem videos ja okay
war ich bei wago drei dabei wie gesagt
du denkst du ist ein falsches spiel ich
weiß ihr wollt das so komplett
ausschließen aber es gebe ja doch so ein
anderes großes spiel
ja ja neben minecraft ok alles klar so
manch parodien bin ich mimi ja wohl wie
wie kannst du dir auf den hier muss auch
jeder kennen herrn aber wenn man wo habe
ich dir denn getroffen
last man standing auto show party weißt
du dich auf den gekommen bin wie ich bin
auf den gekommen weil der und justine
nicht in berlin in meiner wohnung
besucht haben echt ja nicht wegen video
days oder irgendein after-party ok alles
okay mache ich call of duty oder habe
ich konnte diese gemacht als auf dem
video days damals eine million also
fällt erstmal weg ich mach's kopien dem
ersten million
ich glaub nicht oder aber holla die
waldfee das war gerade so was von
fucking heiß alter ja dann bin ich ja
echt okay leute das war's in dieser
folge wer bin ich plötzlich gefallen was